olá ET MA so Jackie Cruz and I'm about
to perform
nvivo McKenzie on Mellie 16 solo para
serious
now made a honey f up in little sweet 16
she had big dreams she solved things
she'll never see
[Music]
I didn't love main alpha P little sweet
16 suck in between me and my dreams felt
and complete
[Music]
stripped away from my own beauty but
everyone could see through me didn't
wanna give you silver new me flashbacks
take me back like a movie now the doors
are open now keeping through the ups and
downs navigate I'm still in rough got
lost and then I found now the doors are
open now even through the ups and downs
navigate I'm still peeing around got
lost and then found be half Audi free to
be half LD innocent girl you meant the
world the things you didn't know
emotional hard to let go
taught me to grow
the strength you saw in me - see clearly
sweet 16 you looked up to me
can you believe what I was destined to
be whoa stripped away from my beauty
thought everyone could see through me
and wanna give you stuff oh no me
flashbacks take me back like a movie
now the doors are open now keeping
through the ups and downs navigating I'm
still around got lost and then I found
now the doors are open now keeping
through the ups and downs navigate I'm
still in route got lost and then I found
me free too baby hey I found me hey
sweet 16
follow me free to be hey hey hey sweet
16
[Music]
really
[Music]
me I found me
[Music]